Great news, the new image generator AI, DALL-E
3 is now available for everyone for free. I’ve
put a link to it in the video description,
make sure to check it out. And it has some
surprises for us, so we are going to
have a look at 6 unexpected results.
First, I read that supposedly, it is excellent
at visualizing proverbs. For instance,
“laughter is the best medicine”. What could
that look like? Oh. Do you remember when we
tested Photoshop’s image generator, and I asked
for an image with caustics, colorful patterns of
reflected light that should look like this, and we
got…this instead? Well, similar phenomenon. Hope
it gets sorted out. Now, luckily, just a week
ago, someone ran the same prompt successfully,
and this is truly excellent. Note that it did
not get detailed instructions on how to do this,
just “laughter is the best medicine”. You
figure out the rest, little AI. Plus points
for the old comic book style. So good!
Midjourney can’t do this. Not even close.
Two, what about character consistency? We got a
taste of this with the amazing Larry the Hedgehog,
however, that was in the promo materials.
Does it also work well in practice? Oh my,
yes it does! This is the same family in four
different settings. Once again, this requires
the implementation of research papers, or at the
very least, a series of tricks in most other text
to image systems. I have to note that I tried it
too, and in my case, it was a little copy-pasty,
you know, it’s easy to keep consistency if you
just copy the same thing over and over, the images
are of somewhat lower quality, so my impression
is that this can be done, but requires a little
cherry picking. That is a huge step forward.
Next step will be that we take it for granted.
Especially that three, this consistency can be
requested in more advanced ways. For instance,
the same character with different ages. This
is one of the best text to image AI results
I have ever seen. Goodness. And hold on to your
papers Fellow Scholars, because it gets better.
If you feed these images into
Runway’s interpolation technique,
you get a fantastic video. I put a link
to these results in the video description,
many of which have prompts available, which
will help you in your own Scholarly experiments.
Four, I was surprised by how good it is at
sketches. This one is incredible. And, of course,
we will get sketches of you Fellow Scholars as
well. Always. But you know what is missing here,
Fellow Scholars is great, but Fellow Scholars
holding on to their papers is even better. Oh,
look at that! Five. Text! Text is finally
working! A historic moment! Glorious!
And finally, six. It is surprisingly imaginative.
It can cook up an image of a relaxing parrot.
Easy. There is room for the tail, and the legs
are up in the air. Really cool! Asking for a
base on the Moon? Not a problem. Paintings are
also incredible. This one just radiates with
joy. Love it. Digital art? It can not only
do it, but it is super imaginative. And now,
what you all have been waiting for. As is
tradition, our legendary stern fox librarian
from DALL-E 2 can now be created again.
Will it get better? It is really good,
and he has gotten a lot more stern this
iteration, I can tell you that right now.
So, yes, DALL-E 3 is really good. No, it is
not perfect. But, really good. Yes, it might
require a little cherry picking. And one more.
And one more. There we go. Thank you, little AI!
And just one more thing. We are in the age of AI,
and I hear more and more rumors about myself
being replaced by an AI who is now narrating
these videos. So let it be known that every
episode is being recorded by my own voice.